why are verbs so important to directing
and acting
because they express Behavior
and that's what we're looking for we're
looking for the behavior of the
characters to tell the story the
behavior of the of the characters in
interaction with each other their
relationships and their behavior in
reaction to good news or bad news
and um and the events of the of the plot
um
so
and and verbs are very important because
they put the actors
focus on the other actor
so if I'm
deciding that my character should be
angry or have been told that my
character is angry then my focus is on
myself am I angry enough
whereas if my I'm using the verb to
punish
then I'm punishing the other person my
focus is on you are you punished yet
I don't know I don't think you're
punished enough
so I'm gonna I'm gonna keep doing it
okay and that that keeps me going and it
keeps it keeps the it keeps the anger
crescendoing actually and I have and not
just crescendoing but having Hills and
Valleys and you know ex you know
expressive expressive uh nuance
okay so because I'm focused on you on
your reaction rather than on me am I
angry enough that's what that that's the
center of why verbs are so helpful
and so what I call the verb family I put
a bunch of things in there the uh the
the active verbs which you could make a
list of demand beg punish seduce flirt
and courage right
um and what you're also called
intentions a lot of these things are
used the terms are used differently by
different people and then there's the
objective which is what the character
wants in the scene
and so strictly speaking the objective
is what the character wants the verb is
what or intention is what they're doing
to get it so if I want you to
um to uh calm down
okay then uh I might hint that I want
you to calm down
maybe you could lower your voice a
little bit
I'm not saying this to you obviously you
have such a lovely sweet voice but uh uh
or but if and but what if I use the
wrong verb you know what if I demand
that you calm down calm down
well it's a it's a very unfortunate verb
to use if you want somebody to calm down
because it's you know it's like with
it's like with dogs right if dogs are
barking and you tell them to stop
barking you're just doing what they want
you to do they just think oh they like
me barking they're barking back so um
anyway people are like that too and and
uh so
so demanding that somebody calmed down
is is is is foolish it doesn't work and
yet people do it all the time
you see it all the time
certainly with their dogs but but but
also with with each other demanding that
somebody uh calm down so people make
mistakes people act irrationally so
verbs are very helpful for finding
irrational Behavior like it would be
irrational to demand that somebody
calmed down but but characters and
people do it all the time
so it's an opposite right it's opposite
to the thing that would that will work
so uh verbs are great for uh okay but
also the so the objective or the need
and also the spine there's a spine a
character may have a spine for the whole
for the whole
um
or the whole script
um and it may not it may not be the same
as the as the scripts as the plot spine
can you explain what that is
the spine the spine it's it's uh it's
who the person is in a kind of very
basic level I I like to say that I think
that this that the person's spine a
character's spine is in place by the
time they're eight years old
so by the time
well
uh
I had a disabled mother
which happened when I was four
so a spine of putting the needs of other
people ahead of my own
was
just happened I didn't choose it but it
happened
right so those things and they follow
you throughout your life and you can
still be a very assertive person which I
am in some ways but that there's it's
something that it's it's it's in your
emotional DNA it's it's it's it's a it's
a part of you
if that makes sense and and and finding
those things it it's helpful for finding
who who the character is who who are
they really so verbs of course work
great for comedy because opposites
because uh because opposites work great
for comedy so if if somebody is
complaining about how they just they uh
somebody that their co-workers uh threw
them a birthday party yeah like they
threw me a birthday party you know that
could be funny
right because it's inappropriate it's an
inappropriate it's incongruous and
inappropriate uh verb for the subject
matter of the that they're talking about
if we can just go back to spying for
women I'm sorry to jump around but no
that's fine I really like that so if we
take Forrest Gump there's two there's
actually several great spines because
there's there's Forest there's Jenny
there's Captain Dan or Lieutenant Dan
sorry there's some there's there's uh
Bubba there's so many spines but if we
just took the two main ones so we see
that Forest
um you know he he sort of has his own
spine of seeming like the one that was
sort of weak but he was actually
stronger than everybody else in many
many ways and and and always kind of
coming out ahead and then we have the
spine of Jenny who unfortunately uh
seemed to repeat itself a lot in her
life
and and and the mother you know played
by Sally Field she had a spine of always
kind of making sure that forest was
treated fairly and that he had it good
so I think I'm now I'm understanding the
spine because at first I didn't know
well I think I would say that forest
forest Gump's spine is to take care of
people
that's what I that's what strikes me is
he takes
uh he takes care of other people
that that's what he always does it's his
another way to think of it is it's his
habitual uh Behavior
is to take care of people
I don't know that that's what just
struck me
and and Jenny of course has a strong
self-destructive streak
and you know and sometimes people have a
spine of punishing themselves
foreign
for whatever reason there's always a
reason
although you know of course it could be
genetic sometimes people are born with
certain proclivities and that becomes
the way that their their lives go
now I'm going to start looking for the
spine I like that and it's a great
analogy too because I think of the spine
of a book almost and just yeah guiding
the people the important thing to
remember is it's not something that the
person chooses
it's but it describes them
and it can be helpful even if it's a
character and people don't know what
their spine is I mean when I said that
about me I don't know if that's true I
think it is but uh but most of the time
people don't know their own spine they
don't think about it and
um and characters still know they're on
spine but it still can be helpful if the
actor does
and it still can be a tool that a that a
director and and and I think if a
director was talking about spying with
an actor to to have it be kind of casual
you know rather than saying okay let's
sit down and decide what your spine is
I I I don't think that's you know
because it starts to feel like you're
filling in blanks but
but if it comes up about the scene well
you know if you're saying well
you know
there's almost this
sense that that for a spine is to take
care of other people
it's an opposite because he actually
needed to be taken care of himself
and of course that brings up the mother
you know it's uh maybe she did such a
good job of taking care of him that he
can he has this serp he has this uh this
uh model of taking care and he has
Surplus
resources to take care of others
and I don't know you start to feel like
okay now that's a family and I I can
understand it a little bit
so just like in life how other people
show us our spine in a movie other
characters will show the protagonist
yes the relationships the relationships
are where or where they come out